if you are a filmmaker and you want to
upload directly to amazon you cannot do
it for subscription based the svod
what do you love about amazon prime
i love that
i love that amazon
like you know sometimes that people
think i suffer from stockholm syndrome
defending amazon but
they opened up independent film
distribution in a way that it had never
in history been done
like amazon
prime made it possible for an
independent filmmaker in indiana making
a six thousand dollar like backyard
horror movie to distribute their film
and have it on the new release wall like
right next to fast and furious you know
that is cool
and and initially
it was paying pretty good i mean i i
don't remember what the what the first
rates were but i think it was like 15 or
20 cents an hour which some people say
like that sounds low but
you can make a lot of money at 20 cents
an hour on a streaming platform on a
platform like amazon where there's like
whatever 90 million users watching
you know
i i
think it was incredible i think they
made mistakes
um you know and i i think the biggest
mistake amazon made was there was
no curation
now you know i keep talking about how
great it is that there was no
gatekeeping or you know no curation but
i think there needed to be a base level
of curation
like they were taking
anything and things that weren't even
movies like you know they they were
taking shorts there were people putting
up like youtube style videos like and i
i think that all of that inappropriate
content is what really like started the
the downfall of it some people will say
that it was always planned that they
were always going to get rid of india
and maybe they were
but i think it at least would have held
on longer had they not been putting out
youtube videos and you know there's a
filmmaker that i know that was putting
his stuff right from youtube onto there
and you know calling them documentaries
but they were not they're like vlogs
like i do you know on there you and i
would never put that on amazon but i
think that's what led led to it
but
i mean
like i owe a lot to amazon it it opened
up my eyes to what
like independent filmmaking could be
financially and and now it's kind of
gone but
other things have popped in you know
like 2b
what are three tips a filmmaker new to
amazon prime should know about getting
their movie up there well so three
things people should know about amazon
the fir first thing is that it's not
what it was so now if you are a
filmmaker and you want to upload
directly to amazon you cannot do it for
subscription based the svod the only
thing that you can do is tv od
and
i think now you can do documentaries
again but for a while they weren't
taking docs at all but i think for tv od
now you can still
submit you know narratives or
documentaries and you'll make you know i
think they pay like 50 of the rental or
the purchase price to you so it sounds
pretty good and if you have if you have
a title
that you know has some legs you know
that that is good that might have some
stars you might do good with tv od
but the first thing to know though is
that you can't
you know you can't just upload and be
free with prime anymore you have to go
through a distributor or an aggregator
and and they're pickier than they were
so like like you know some chintzy
things are still getting up but not not
like it was before so it's harder um
then now so let's say you're going
through a distributed aggro you get and
you get up there so what are some things
that you need to know in order to do
well there i think filmmakers need to
like wrap their heads around
i'm trying to so
what i where i learned this from was
doing youtube so when i started growing
my youtube channel i started watching
all these youtube growth experts right
people with you know three four hundred
thousand subscribers and they're talking
about this is how we grew our business
and they start talking about looking at
analytics they start say thinking about
hooking the audience early and keeping
them engaged and giving the audience
what they need and
i started thinking about my features
like that you know so like
you know like now i would be much more
hesitant to do like you know a movie
that had an opening like slow burn 20
minutes
like i i would i i would be hesitant to
throw that up for something that's going
to perform on a streaming platform
because in today's day and age you know
they used to say like with screenplays
you have 10 pages like you know to hook
the person
not anymore you got like you got like 60
seconds like if something is not
happening that is gonna engage the
audience early on
they're out of there so like you like
you front you gotta front load some good
stuff
you know so i think about that um
and then i've talked about um
you know uh
like engaging in in the algorithm so
you know when you're typing out your
description and even if you're going
through a distributor nine times out of
ten filmmakers are still writing their
own synopsises and stuff like that so
start thinking about that that is your
first
like thing to start thinking about like
seo you know search engine optimization
so like using keywords and and you want
it and you need to be able to blend
those keywords into your you know
sentence and paragraph so it sounds
organic and not clunky but you know
you're thinking like i'm doing a uh
i'm doing a horror movie with you know
zombies and vampires right zombies
versus vampires so like you want
zombies
in your description and in a couple
different ways you want like zombies
undead um you know try to tank try to
think of like three different terms for
like zombies and then try to think of
maybe three terms for vampires and then
try to find a way within that paragraph
to work as many of those in as you can
you know and because these like amazon
there when people search like these
keywords
come up and they're they're matching you
know audiences with their keywords so
it's you know it's important so
think about that um and then um you know
think about where you're gonna what what
kind of movies like do better on amazon
and amazon
isn't a super like like indie indie
friendly thing now so like if you are
doing an indie film
the indie films are going to do better
on amazon are going to be stuff that
have a little more of a like like a
mainstream feel like a little less
nichey you know or
you know they have and no no extreme
like violence or sex or drugs like you
really gotta it's all it's really weird
because i remember when i started i used
to always say hey if you're gonna make a
ten thousand dollar movie you might as
well just go balls to the wall and throw
it all out there and not worry about
nothing this is the time to be punk rock
not necessarily if you want to if you
want to make any money off of them
because you know and then now
that uh avods are starting to take off a
lot more than the subscription-based
platforms you know stuff like 2b or imdb
tv or even youtube
now those uh you know you're getting
paid from the advertisers and the
advertisers have to be matched with your
stuff so
the advertisers that pay the best are
usually more for quadranty you know
so like you know on youtube for example
you know if you have a documentary about
cannabis you're not going to make
anything because you're going to they're
they're going to 18
like restrict you and the you're going
to have a really low cpm and you won't
make much money
so you need to you think about those
things too
but if you have a narrative about a dog
that saves christmas
perfect perfect for amazon
christmas dog movie oh man you know a
friend of mine is actually doing a
christmas uh pig movie right now okay
and he's doing very well on
youtube actually yeah very cool
what about um cover art
uh
most important thing uh for the
marketing of the film is the cover art a
lot a lot of people will say trailer
nope cover art because like in this in
the streaming like
that is the thing that gets people to
stop it's the art it is if you're gonna
spend money on something like for
marketing
spend it on your cover art like if
you're a decent graphic artist but you
can come up with you know a thousand or
you know 5 000 or whatever
pay the money and get a pro
one sheet done if you can
you know i i so i'm a decent graphic
artist and for my first probably year
like doing docs i was just doing all my
own i was like this is good enough this
is good enough this is good enough and
then you know one day i was like you
know what i'm gonna try i'm gonna i'm
gonna hire somebody out so you know i
hired a graphic designer i think i paid
600 bucks for it and
it did way better than my average stuff
so then from then on everyone i put the
money into it